[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are going into uncharted
territory you said uncharted that's well
it sorry you you said shard I said
uncharted but I have this toothpick in
my mouth I certainly hope this is
uncharted territory because I do not
have plans to shark in the next hour or
so I thought it would be a good idea to
have this toothpick as I was coming back
here to sit down
I walked by the front desk and you know
usually we have like gum up there so in
which I'm not gonna chew gum but maybe
there's a mint
watch.you gum so I gaze in that
direction as I'm walking by and I'm like
what is that plastic box you know in it
he gives me pause looked more closely
and it's toothpicks and I'm like what
the world and there why would that
surprise you a lot because there are
toothpicks support because it said
flavored toothpicks it's like it's
better than they're just regular well
what's good though some like what flavor
is good I'm like flavored toothpicks
what flavor cinnamon all of them are
cinnamon and then someone a mythical
crew member who shall remain nameless
said oh yeah I quit smoking with those I
was like you just needed something
dangling from your lips in order to quit
smoking good for you they quit smoking
with those meaning they were previously
lighting those on fire and smoking they
were smoking cigarettes and this is the
method that they used it's kind of like
Hank Williams jr. using life savers to
get off cigarettes what is that line I
use life savers to help me get it off
cigarettes but you know for your love
ain't found no life savers yeah
we won't sing the whole song but you
should listen to the whole song but the
tuffet okay we won't um so old habits
I thought Hank Williams jr. good song I
thought I would give it a shot and then
lo and hold right off the bat I said
sharted
well cause it's just because of the
flavor toothpick if it wasn't flavored
you would have definitely hit the chin
chart no it's just it's just dangling
right there it doesn't make me what I
was trying to say was we're going down
the rabbit hole in this episode we've
got an envelope there we do not know
what's inside of it a completely
uncharted rabbit hole but I mean totally
clean rabbit hole if you I mean if you
didn't know me a video version of this
podcast or just met me on the street and
we had a conversation I had this
toothpick dangling from my lips like I
do right now
douche bag douche bag or a hayseed
hillbilly you don't know I mean there's
nothing else about you if yes you start
talking that would that would make me
think that you were a hillbilly yeah and
so a straight two douche bag now would
bypass hillbilly straight two douche bag
what about former smoker I mean I'm
saying this as a person who recently
wore sunglasses during an entire episode
of ear biscuits which was the ultimate
douche move and I I caught it on on the
Twitter and the Instagram and the people
who took the screenshots etc people who
got it out of context just like I
predicted said what is Rhett thinking
who does he think Diddy it yeah yeah
won't do it again well that's why I'm so
probably will I'm getting rid of this
toothpick because it it messes up the
audio experience as well you want it try
it
that's not how to fix work use the other
end no I can imagine what it tastes like
this cinnamon kind of makes my lips burn
tell me something I don't know well I
wanted to talk to you a little bit
before we get into the rabbit hole now
first of all these will be a sponsor in
a couple of weeks and and we'll talk
about how great these are will be what
will both be having them the whole ear
biscuit sure definitely the price is
right
I went hiking family hike you know
sometimes when you've got a weekend and
you begin feeling like your children are
spending too much time with the media
and I don't mean like the news media I
mean like you know screens we call it
leaking information to the media you're
just like we got to get out yeah gotta
do something as a family yeah and
interestingly when you live in Los
Angeles
unlike when you live in North Carolina
you know when I was a kid if you got
stir-crazy you just went outside and
there was woods behind my house that you
could kind of explore indefinitely and
there was like there's just a whole
world that you could kind of explore you
got it if you get bored with that
there's manholes you can pry open that
we go down in the sewer but we did that
it's kind of a combination of the fact
that it's 2018 and this doesn't happen
as much and also the places that we live
you just don't let your kids just hey
kids just go out in the neighborhood and
I'll see you in a few hours like that
just doesn't really happen that much no
and so you have to orchestrate outings
you either like take them to somebody's
house where they've kind of got some
room or something like that but most
often it's like let's go to a place that
has been dated I'm gonna take you to
somebody's house they've got a room or
something here I'm sure you just just
have a blast but typically the way it
works is you find a space that the
people of the Greater Los Angeles area
have deemed appropriate for outdoor
activities sometimes that is a city park
that gets old but one of the cool things
that we do have is you just had a little
bit outside of time town and you got
these you're you're in you're in Angeles
National crest Angeles National Forest
that's a National Forest I don't know
exactly what that means but it's a
National Forest
it is recognized on a national level as
being a forest that's something to say
you know we you said it brother
and so we went I have the adventure Pass
you got to have the adventure Pass just
to get into the National Forest and park
your car
I don't know exact
know why but we drove up into you bend
up to little I don't know if it's little
or big Tujunga Canyon no the Tujunga
Canyon is a canyon that goes up into the
Angeles National Forest and I guess it's
Tujunga Creek or anyway there's a
there's a there's a hiking trail up
there does it burn - that's where the
fires were some places were burned okay
but I but I grabbed the family I put
them in the car
we brought barb along with us because
she also is into the media I mean Barbie
get your dog off of screens yeah yeah
she loves cable news I mean she will
just salivate over Cable News she can't
get enough of it people yelling at each
other and so we had to pull her away
from that and she needs grooming right
now she's got a little too much hair but
it sounds a little bit worried cuz it
was getting to be like an 80 degree day
and we were gonna be hiking and lots of
Sun I think I saw you on the way there
didn't you pass me oh yeah cuz you were
dropping off Lily anatoly's friend at
her house yep yeah I passed you I saw I
saw all of you in the car and I gave you
a head nod yeah you didn't deny Otis you
didn't you didn't stop and I I'd seen
you I'd seen you the night before yeah
no need to
no need to reconvene no so I could tell
you were on your way to a National
Forest I'm a hat on yeah you had I don't
see the sunscreen no really prepped up I
rubbed it in you got to put sunscreen on
at least 30 minutes before exposure did
Barbara get hard or something she did
well we get out on the trail and these
are the things that we dealt with as a
family
number one is your family this way when
you hike is it not peaceful
I mean it's being peaceful but first of
all I know it's never peaceful from this
full from the moment you know I got home
and I we actually went for what I did
not call a hike I said alright kids
you're getting off screens a nature walk
nature I said make sure is the only
other thing it could be you've tried
that No
but I should have yeah I call it a
nature walk very science and they just
roll their eyes they're like dad you're
trying to take us on a hike no it's the
place that we're gonna go is relatively
flat yeah cuz take a hike is got a
negative confident connotation but take
a nature walk is like well I'm in field
trip
yeah it's about nature walk is is
implies no incline no no no no grueling
nature to it right just shade it also
feels useful we were not in the shade we
were in the extreme heat I did an
orientation before we got started
because apparently rattlesnakes are
really bad this year more on that later
okay that's what they call a teaser and
so I I was like kids you got you got to
stay on the path
do not go traipsing off into the the
this the the the grass is because
they're snakes in the grasses and I
don't want you to get bit by a
rattlesnake I don't want to deal with
that today yep it would inconvenience
you would be a horrible that day for dad
if kid got bit by rattle Sania yeah so I
there's nothing more inconvenient than a
child losing the use of a limb right so
I I'm out on the trail and again it's
not peaceful because we can't seem to
have a conversation without somebody
having a problem with something else
that somebody says everybody in my
family has a strong will me included and
eventually I was like let's just be
quiet for a little bit and just hear the
sound of our dog panting cuz she was and
that sounds of her own footsteps and the
nature walk and this trail by the way
highly recommended if you're in the
Greater Los Angeles area
I think it's called Tujunga Canyon
waterfall trail or something question
mark when you search it put a question
mark at the end and it's like a two mile
hike that continues to rise in elevation
as you follow along and first of all
you're inside the National Forest but
right at the top of the trail there's
all these people who I don't know how
they're doing it they're living out
there in houses that look like houses
that have been there for a long time
that we're like Ranger cabins or
something I've seen this in my places
but they they're like grandfathered in
so even though there's gay
that you can't drive through they have a
gauge of the game has a key to the game
they'll drive up in there and just live
there and there'll be signs that says
private residence yeah there was a guy
in a Mazda don't mess with me I'm not
don't ask me questions about your nature
walk yeah it said private do not disturb
your residents yeah yeah I didn't but I
was so interested in what their like
wanted to disturb him so bad I bet they
had screens I heard at least I heard I
heard audio I heard definite meat radio
something was going on and maybe AM
radio listening like the Grand Ole Opry
or something and but I was fascinated
with that and then I you know me I have
a tendency when introduced to a new
environment I have a tendency to
continue to point out what I think is
cool about it it's just in my nature to
be like and then I have a tendency to
try to get the people that I'm with to
also think to share an enthusiasm and I
do that to me I think it's a dad thing
in general but I'm like hey guys isn't
this awesome these people live up here
and and they're all kind of like I'm
kind of glad we don't live up here I'm
like is it that isn't this cool isn't
this the fact that this is so close to
our house awesome and then Locke is like
dad why do you always have to try to get
us to like things yeah yeah because
you're not saying how much you like it I
take the kids to school
a few times a week is it's it I
considered a special occasion yeah and
I'm taking Lillian Lincoln to school and
the way that I go is down this one
particular street and there's this one
house that has a whole bunch of trees
which is unusual and cool it's like a
forest so every time I and then right
the house right beside it has a bunch of
cacti Oh even cool huh so every time I
go by it I'm like hey look at that
cactus and then and they hate it yeah
they don't want to be told what Lily
Lily hates it
she's like dad don't now before I say
anything she's like point out the cactus
dad and then the very next light there's
all these trees and I'm like look at
that one tree it grew and then it went
sideways it's growing its shaped like a
lightning bolt yeah and they're like we
don't care she's so annoyed by it
get it my whole family hates me for it
for purchase for just enjoying life I'm
a cookie butter I mean yeah I spot corn
things are cool and I like to point him
out I guess somehow when I start saying
is cool it's no longer cool and
matter-of-fact so defeated right before
I saw you on the way to the National
Park when I was dropping off Lily's
friend at her house we went down the
same street and Lily goes dad I just
want to warn you dad is going to point
out this cactus and then he's gonna
point out this tree that shaped like a
lightning bolt and I was like I'm a
kidder and I drove right past it I
didn't say a word didn't point out any
figure that does she stupid nature walk
stupid so the highlight of the trip
though was when we got to the end and
Barbara was having a very difficult time
Barbara is not used to this again
watches a lot of cable news spends a lot
of time inside in fact when you get the
leash we're ready to walk her she goes
underneath the couch she does not want
to go outside she has such a diva she
has a lot of energy inside the house
she's got she's losing energy man she's
losing it she just two and a half now
depleting she just lost she likes to get
love and to give love and that's about
it okay and but we get down to the place
where we're gonna descend to the
waterfall which by the way best
waterfall in the local area as far as I
could tell I showed you a little video
of the yeah but I was amazed like a
30-foot waterfall with a with a with a
swimmable little pool at the bottom that
is done yeah I mean it's incredible also
a little crowded because of that because
it is Los Angeles even if you're way out
there but we get to a place where you
have to descend down to the waterfall
via a very steep incline in a rope you
have to it's a back down linking rope
belay into the yeah are you like right
beside the waterfall no this is about a
hundred yards down from the waterfall
but this is the place to get down to the
creek to walk back up cuz you've been on
an incline that's getting steadily
steadily higher and further away from
the creek and then you kind of come back
down to the creek so all of a sudden you
weren't pointing out something that was
cool you're like look kids a rope oh
crap
Locke and Shepard had all
we got way ahead of us and descended
down into you know the canyon and I got
up there and Jessie was she was like
you're gonna be able to I mean how are
we gonna get Barbara down and then I saw
a woman not sure at that moment a woman
pulls herself up to the top of the cliff
with a baby in a Bjorn
oh yeah at that point I'm like can I
borrow your Bjorn at that point I'm like
well I even if I or Barbara or both of
us die in this process it's worth it
because a woman with a with a newborn
baby just ascended the cliff it's worth
it or that she challenged chignon verbs
she put my pride on the spot right so I
went down with one hand on the rope one
hand on Barbara because Barbara is ginn
if you put her down on the slow she'll
just literally lay down and will not
move she had done that multiple times
every time she got to a shady spot she
just laid down he had to kind of hug her
on her on her leash she's like I know
you're coming back this way I'll be here
on the flip side after some intense rope
burn on my right hand I did get down and
then I got to the bottom and I looked up
and I was like the real problem is not
getting down it's getting back up but
let's not think about that now you have
to do let's enjoy the waterfall again
there was three ladies friends who were
up there enjoying the waterfall and I go
out there and my kids are yelling at
each other and pushing each other and I
like just guys show some respect
I'm gonna do dad mode and like these
women enjoy themselves of course if
we're gonna stay here I'm okay
you can't help going into dad mode you
know if it don't you have any self
respect for these women if they're not
joining themselves if you're not
pointing out something cool your your
reprimanding kids yeah and then once I
got em to start pushing on each other
and I'm by this time I notice these
ladies are laughing cuz this is like a
sitcom that they're they're witnessing
then I'm like hey lot take a picture of
me and mom and this waterfall oh gosh I
had to redirect his frickin picture
seven times because I was like listen I
want us and the waterfall the whole
waterfall from the top to the bottom and
by the end I'm speaking like that
trying to get it's a nice picture of me
and my wife just take the freakin
picture
and the women are still there watching
the show they're loving everything about
it so then we have to leave and at that
point they begin to talk to us and they
say how are you gonna I don't know how
you're gonna get out that awful if I was
like I don't either but then I said you
want a dog witness aw did anything cuz
they mega would have had the same
problem I assume you ladies live down
here so what I ended up doing is putting
a ticking everything out of my day pack
putting it around like a Bjorn in the
front strapping it in the back so that
it was nice and secure opening up giving
this stuff that I had the snacks and
stuff to Jessie and she put it in this
weird fashionable double fanny pack that
she was wearing never seen that before
she just broke it out for the nature
walk and then I put probably had that
for four years I put Barbara inside this
thing and Barbara no likey the bag she
wants to get out and so I have to hold
her in the bag which kind of defeats the
purpose of the bag but it is easier than
actually holding the her whole bunch her
in the head and knocked her out that
like ba Baracus that was Plan B it ate
here you know every time the a-team
traveled they had to knock him out you'd
think he would know it was coming but
every episode where they have to fly but
it was a shot they knock him out yeah
we're the with the drug okay no
sometimes he'd get punched in the face
yeah but MA but a lot of times it was it
was it was an injection incorrectly
either way he should have known it was
coming
you know the 18 theme song plays on my
phone all the time you know how it's the
first song by alphabetical order in my
iTunes and so when my phone hits the
signal sometimes with Bluetooth I've
heard the beginning of the a-team song
at least 1500 times I can think of no
better song for that to be the case 1982
a team of oh it has the voice uh-oh yeah
I should have anyway so I i bypassed the
rope I had to bypass the rope and climb
up the cliff without the rope because it
was actually easier to just grab hold of
rocks while holding on a Barbara
actually wasn't that bad
oh I got back up felt a little bit like
a hero and then silently nature walk
back to the car did you keep her in the
bag the rest of the time no she got out
as soon as she got to the top and she
was panting I noticed when she gets
really hot she pants a lot and her tail
which is normally up falls down it's
like a
monitor did she have water man yeah we
had a little cute little pink little
collapsible thing that we would put
water in and she had plenty of water she
just didn't like the idea of the nature
walk
anyway I suggest hiking with your family
we're gonna open an envelope here in a
second but first let's plug some
mythical merch shall we let's do that
look at this this is the good mythical
summer camp shirt featuring yours truly
and Link around a campfire that has the
GM M logo coming out of the fire as it
as it is there's some details in the
background that you're really gonna
appreciate when you have it on your
person you're looking down at it this is
a ring T we recently were given reason
to believe that this makes you look more
muscular when you wear it
I wore it in this will it slip and slide
episode and in good mythical more oh
we're spitting watermelon seeds I'm
reading the comments I'm like everybody
somehow is linked working out link looks
buff and I'm like it must be that shirt
let it literally I'm sure that it's the
shirt
well the shirt has a lot to do with it
so I'm yourself a ring T and you don't
have to work out yeah just it makes you
it makes you look muscular mythical dots
store that's the website thanks for
supporting in turn 18 with all your
needs okay you want to open up this
envelope I do I get a little nervous at
this point like what can it be
oh gosh that could have been smoother if
we don't talk we're gonna have to put a
drum roll in there okay okay Carolyn one
seven nine eight zero seven four two
because a lot of other Carolyn's were
taken asks or actually demands find the
15th picture in your phone camera album
what is it and give us the backstory
behind it oh wow
Winky emoji this is hmm I got a lot of
pictures now my phone here's the thing
about pictures in my phone I have I have
every picture I've ever taken in my
phone
because I sim I recently went through
the tough work of moving all of my
pictures to Google photos which which
then uh you know they update to the
cloud immediately back out to years
organized by years like I just did go to
collections on the look on the lower
part there are you know you're on your
you're saying you're in Google pictures
okay yeah the first Alma the first
picture I have is from February of 2004
well the first picture I have is 2000
October 9th 2003 oh my gosh okay so
before we answer her question let's look
at the first picture well the very first
picture I have from February 2004 is a
picture of my driver's license
Christie's driver's license my social
security number card and Chrissy so she
put that on the screen little is that
let's let's roll that with no censoring
look at you shouldn't have that on your
freaking phone man why is that why do
you have that well I got my driver's
like is in my pocket what's the
difference okay I just feel like having
it digit having it just and I'll get the
picture of me I never remember having
this configuration of facial hair I
remember thinking that I should talk to
you about it I have I've got the hair of
defeat like I've got engineering here
well I can't teii I I have a goatee with
no mustache let me see it's a goatee but
I have no I did not I like did this for
one day and it was the day I got my you
did I was more than one day you did it
for more than one day I don't remember
that but the also and then the next
picture I have is from January 2006
you're gonna go through all the pictures
yeah it's a picture of me and me and
Christie in front of our white minivan
oh that was a good minivan this was a
picnic that Christian I went on when we
this is in the little patch of grass
beside the Imperial theater in Cary
North Carolina we went to see a movie
now you do know that it's Caroline asked
for the 15th picture oh I know I was
just sidetracked by but what's the
oldest picture
Matthieu I will say the oldest picture I
have is from October 9th 2003 and it is
my pregnant wife oh wow
and I Wow standing in front when I say
oh wow a couple of times I'm making fun
of myself because I hate it when I say
oh well oh wow yeah and whenever I say
it I say it again and then I realized no
one knows I'm making fun of myself they
just think I'm saying oh wow
twice yeah say it three times then oh
wow so this was in rather pregnant when
we this is October 2003 lock was born in
February 2004 so she had a good five
months to go
but she's standing in front of a closet
door which is weird oh this is I think
she slept this is not a closet door this
is the door a thin door to our bedroom
what this is when we lived above my
in-laws garage remember that so we lived
in Chapel Hill bought that house in
Chapel Hill and then we moved out to
move to Fuquay yeah while we're getting
ready to buy the house in Fuquay oh yeah
been a whole year the Backhouse living
in her parents back house above the
garage which was the door that thin
because it was do everything was small
man everything was small and that's
that's the that's he's almost so
pregnant she can't fit through the door
that's the door going into the bedroom
which I couldn't stand up in but let me
tell you I didn't need to okay yeah
because you slept in there it's a
bedroom you jerk man remember back when
our wives are pregnant yeah boy when
Chrissy was pregnant with all three kids
we slept in a double bed I mean and went
but not with the children with the in
the belly yes yeah yeah I know but you
just made it sound like your whole
family slept in a double bed and would I
know that's not what you meant what you
meant was the two of you slept in a
double bed now the three of us but one
was in utero and so very very very
recently actually yeah relatively
recently I didn't get a queen-size bed
until well if you're if if if your
partner's pregnant I'm choking up a part
of pregnant it's a beautiful thing duh I
think you need at least a queen bed if
you're gonna keep sleeping with him
because I don't know how you did that
man she would roll over and it would
it would it would be like a it would be
like an act of God for her ólafur I mean
like the tides would shift yeah it's
like it's like the the there's a lunar
part of the equation you're drinking a
glass of water and like I mean it was
that it got to be that big you know and
then when she would I mean she would
have to roll over it was an event she
would have to roll over like one of
those hot dogs in a 7-eleven like I'm
sure that she even plays this I'm glad
she doesn't listen to the podcast
she started listening to oh she has I
got one of them now but she would both
of us would have to roll over in place
like a hot dog in you know until my on
like the rollers in the 7-eleven where
it does I'm fully or it doesn't change
its location it just changes its
orientation and she had to do that with
a I mean and you can't I can fully roll
over like a hot dog but when you have a
baby in your belly yeah can you imagine
having to do that no boy I'm glad that
was over I didn't it made me
uncomfortable being that close to a
human being inside of a human being yeah
yeah because it just meant I mean it
just it it was uncomfortable for her you
just feel like you see some you can hurt
somebody but we were so close I mean
like we were we were it the thing that
we loved about it was the room our
bedrooms are always small so it wasn't
just a bed and nothing else that we were
able to have other furniture that's how
small our bedrooms always work and it
also made us physically more close to
one another so but you can you know then
add it you can't do that in a king bed
you can also not do that you have an
option right but it kind of forces
together so if we were having a fight
you know it's a good habit to not not
let the Sun go down and you own your
anger so to speak do you need to resolve
it before the next day it kind of forced
us to do that
because you can't you can't be in like a
big argument with somebody and then hop
in bed and just spoon I think I can well
which we in fact spoon in the Front's
first I don't I don't recall but I've
known I've gotten in bed man
before and my wife is also mad but you
still spoon what you know you bet you
have a king bed spoon Friday you've
never had a double bed uh no yeah
fried from the beginning we went I mean
I'm a big man you know I need him I need
a big bed I mean I'm not shaming you
that was one of the things I was most
excited about getting married was a
king-size bed California king I went
straight to California before I ever
moved to California I was in California
when I was in North Carolina that's how
much I was into it but a California king
is not longer it is just wider nope it's
just longer it's not it's actually more
narrow oh is that so a typical king bed
is 80 by 80 but a California king is 84
by 76 is 84 inches long 76 so you're a
little bit closer but your feet don't
hang off if you're the rester I should
do commercials if you're a California
King company contest so you need you
need that extra four inches did not have
your feet hang off the bed if I if I if
I got some a couple of extra pillows
yeah I mean yeah you never slidin down
you never know I mean we like regular
king-size bed I get close to the edge
yes definitely
you mean the end the end or the edge
whatever you want to call it can I count
to my 15th picture and no it's a rabbit
hole man now I sleep with mine but that
doesn't mean you don't answer the
question my dog and she takes up too
much I'm just gonna dog I'm gonna need
just a pregnant to count to 15 just
count out of 15 9 10 11 12 13 14
oh gosh oh gosh I'm not gonna be able to
show this picture without permission
it's my it's my wife in the hospital bed
is she she just had the baby hold on you
went 15 from the back you went 15 the
wrong you counted the wrong direction
the 15th picture in your the 15th
picture in your phone camera album oh I
thought it meant from the from most
recent well we can do that to link but
that typically would be that's why I was
so happy to be going all the way
yeah I thought we were off off-topic the
whole time we were very close we cuz
they to go back to the first one to do
report to noon if we have 14 off I
thought we were like thousands away I
deal with this all the time by the way
hey it's a common mistake when you sleep
in cramped environments your whole life
but this is okay so this is well Jessie
is waiting I mean I'm not going I'm not
I'm not going to show I'm not gonna talk
about this picture too much because I'm
not gonna show it I don't want to
frustrate you but I'll just tell you
it's my wife lying in the hospital bed
and her parents next to her her dad is
caught with his eyes closed in a weird
expression the baby has not been
delivered yet baby still in the belly
and somebody is somebody's hand is in
the frame with a sippy cup of some sort
probably probably my sister-in-law with
a sippy cup for her second oldest son
who is just like a year and a half older
than life it could be a nurse because
right when that baby pops out you know
the first thing you do is slam a sippy
cup in their hand let them let them get
hydrated they're more interesting stuff
I'm seeing around around that can't talk
about it
not 15 is the pictures that we took
before let me count mine then you can go
to that okay unless you want to go to
well it's not that interesting it's just
I remember we had a meal and I was like
this is the last meal we'll ever have as
two people as opposed to three as the
McLaughlin family again my wife doesn't
want me to show you pictures of her the
day before she had her baby that would
be that would be like talking about your
wife and how turning her turning over
while pregnant is like being a hot dog
at the 7-eleven it's not the kind of
thing I was just saying she had to do
this now the kind of thing a
self-respecting person does with the
help of God all right now should I count
duplicates because do you know what I
think this gives you the option to do
both why don't you go 15 with duplicates
and then 15 but bypassing the duplicates
one - oh I clicked on it
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven twelve thirteen fourteen
fifteen yeah that one's that's nothing
so if I do skipping nothing you can't
just say nothing you have to say what it
is and tell us why it doesn't matter
okay this is it's my father-in-law with
one of my children I can't tell which
one it was
they all look the same when they're kids
yeah that's Lincoln you're right I was
just joking and a guitar when Lincoln
when Lincoln was a baby he was obsessed
with the guitar he would call it my tar
give me my tar he's probably he's not
two years old I mean no one eighteen
months max one and a half yeah and he
would go crazy for this guitar I I see
here's another picture of him see he's
playing the guitar there and that's it
that's not it
my father-in-law's house that's it my
nanny's house my mom's mom I don't want
to frustrate the I got all the audio
listeners too much though okay while we
can well I'm not gonna I don't think I'm
gonna show any of these pictures I could
talk to my wife about it but it's just
you know she'd rather me not show
pictures of the very late stages of her
pregnancy okay so because of the hot dog
yes and so out of respect for her I
won't do that so out of respect for you
listener and watch her I'm not gonna
talk too much about them this is a
picture they make me think about yeah
Lincoln was obsessed with guitars and he
would just go nuts if you took the
guitar away from him like one time at
nanny's house we took the guitar away
from him in order to I don't know leave
or do something else and he went so
ballistic like he started screaming and
throwing a tantrum and he turned so red
that then he started to turn blue like
everyone got legitimately scared and
then gave him the guitar back and he was
totally fine
I mean it's like even from that young of
an age it's like sometimes you just you
can't win you know you have to lose it
seems like they're gonna they're gonna
die are you saying you don't want to
look at any other pictures
no no I'm well did you did you find your
actual 15th with duplicates let me do
that 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
oh it's the other guitar picture the one
that I already talked about that's the
that's the actual 15th if you count hmm
so nothing there well the thing that
this makes me think about in general is
that our only pictures when you go back
to the first digital pictures that we
took yeah
are these pictures that are very much
like family oriented like and I look at
all the pictures from 2004 and 2005 and
it's just my kids it's just all my kids
it was like that was those were the
occasions to take pictures thought about
this quite a bit and our you know our
kids were born like we were born in a
really interesting time when it comes to
the way that our lives were catalogued
right so for us there's absolutely no
evidence no video evidence of us up
until middle school at the earliest and
I think that probably I mean the the
Oedipus video that was online at some
point and I think you still have
somewhere yeah we that was like a school
project video that's the first video
that we ever yeah that that a that is
amongst if not the first now eighth
grade video evidence of us that is
available out there was we were already
one we were already teenagers basically
like 13 years old and then of course
there's not really anymore
I mean there once we started of course
a little bit as we got older and then
once we hit you know we didn't really
get started in this business until mid
late 20s and so and then from then on
there's too much evidence of us you know
yeah you can't get away from it
but with our kids they were born at a
time when you know when our kids were
born the phones that we were using did
not have cameras yeah so remember being
obsessed with getting a small video
camera that I could like keep in my
pocket and then I finally picked out the
one that I wanted it was like some sort
of cannon it was like you held it like a
gun and then it had a thing that
yeah-ha-ha on the side it was very small
and within the first couple of weeks I
he got stolen or I lost it or something
somehow I and then I never replaced it
well I was like man one day this will be
in the phone like video capability but
we both had we both had digital 8 sony
digital 8 cameras yeah each bought one
you know and in our very first stuff
that we ever shot was shot on those
digital 8 like a mini a digital 8 tape
which is a small tape that then I can't
remember exactly how this worked but
because it was digital but this was
still like 1997 1998 there's a college
yeah but we continued to use that
technology yeah up until like in fact
just recently I took all my there was
like 4 hours of video footage that I
captured on my honeymoon
whoa I don't know how I got 4 hours
worth of video must have been bored I
was I was busy that was another thing I
was videoing everything and just like
we're constantly running this video
camera we've never ever looked at any of
it in just six weeks ago I took all
those tapes including a bunch of other
tapes that I had just random stuff took
it to a place in Burbank and they
digitized the whole thing and then gave
me a drive I haven't looked
oh you have a drive I have a drive with
all that footage on it so Jesse you know
at some point with the kids after I
probably screen it are gonna look down
look at all this this footage but it's
it's crazy to think about the you should
have paid them to edit it down to a four
and a half minute montage what they did
they look at all of it or did they like
mindlessly press play on a tape well in
digitize when we asked them to because
they had it for a few weeks when we
asked them what the status was they were
like we're doing some color correction
or something like that like what I think
what they do is they have some like
effect that they can put on there too
they know that okay Digital 8 tape
that's from this time it isn't like
they're going through and literally
analyzing every scene they're like doing
like a overall post-treatment to it but
it made it sound like we've been
reviewing your four hours of honeymoon
footage and by the way it's also stored
or locally on our server you know like I
hopefully they've deleted everything I
don't know how it works at privacy
issues and that kind of thing but I'm
thankful for the service but and I have
sporadic what I'm getting to is the is
the the record of our kids lives that we
have and how they were born in this
really weird time in which we began to
have the ability to video them with
these weird formats so actually yeah
there was a there was a Sony camera that
I had that was a still camp went and
shoot but then it had a VIP video
capability and it created a file that
was this proprietary Sony thing and I
took all my video of lock in his first
year with the most of my video with lock
in his first year maybe even more that
with this video with this camera and
then in the process of my library
getting backed up and you know how it's
like you get a new computer and it like
moves over and then it moves to iCloud
and there were there was before iCloud
there was something else and anyway
through this process can't open him you
can't get to any of those in fact
they're no longer video files there's
now that I can't open them I had these
video files
and it's the only thing that has saved
at this point is just the thumbnail a
still image from that video and it's
heartbreaking you know I don't have that
part of his life because he was born in
2004 the time when everybody was coming
up with weird video formats to put on
your little point and shoot camera and
then shepard had the benefit of being
born in 2008 and it was just the time
between 2004 and 2008 i got to a place
where i was using a camera that i can
actually access those files you are an
early adopter man i was just like
everybody else everybody i mean in that
time and if i'm sorry if that's how lot
finds out that he's adopted that's the
story to tell him before now I mean I
kind of feel like I don't want to look
it like I have a box of that same type
of footage I actually have that digital
8 camera that you refer to I have mine I
also have yours oh thanks
I don't know how but I have both of them
in storage along with a bunch of tapes
double-barrel and I can have those
digitized too if this works out for you
but I'm really hesitant to do it there's
something severely depressing that I
experience when I look back at old
videos like I can barely bring myself to
do it because it makes me it just feels
like I don't know I'm just overwhelmed
with sadness when I watch it can you
relate to that I can't even articulate
exactly why email I must have to do with
like it's much more complicated than
just thinking that I'm getting old
well I yeah it's like oh my gosh so much
so much has happened and but it's
interesting that I don't the only way I
will remember a lot of things is if I
were to look at old photos or videos the
videos are hard to look at too so it
takes effort you have to sit down you
have to do it but it just it seems like
it's this bittersweet experience that
ultimately has an overarching
sadness well I understand what you're
saying and it is difficult to articulate
the other emotion that enters me when
I'm looking at this stuff is this sense
that there's a frustration there's a
2-part frustration there's a frustration
with I don't know it's like I got those
files of Locke at that kid I'll never
get to look I really every time I go
back to old photos and old videos I get
frustrated with the fact that I lost
that mm then I start trying to talk
myself into it doesn't matter because
he's here and it's just like what is
this really gonna impact other than like
his rehearsal dinner you know what I'm
saying right like it's like oh we didn't
get to there's a little gap there in the
videos of luck but then there's this
frustration that sets him with shouldn't
I do something with this like like added
it you should not edit this innocent and
so not too many years ago I took like a
look like we actually have some some of
Locke's birth I guess I used a different
video camera mm-hmm it was like his
birth I got but an it was like I
transitioned to a new camera when he
came home and that's where I lost but I
took it and like made it into like you
know a five minute video that like kind
of captured his birth and then it's got
some music and that kind of thing but
there's a sense I should do something
with this and and that's why I haven't
looked at that the honeymoon footage
because I'm sure it'll be fun but
there's also this like sense of like I
gotta do something with this now but
because it's four hours of footage but
here what I have noticed is the
technology you know it's getting better
all the time and what they've done now
you'll notice this and I'm sure this is
available on other services but if you
if you've got an iPhone now they take
they take your videos and your photos
when you go off on a trip and they
recognize that you were at a specific
location and they create what they're
calling a memory and this is guy I guess
this has been around for at least a year
but I didn't notice it until a few
months ago oh yeah when all of a sudden
I had like oh we went to Palm Springs
and here's a nice little video with and
I can change the music and I can take it
it's
the AI began to make the video for me
and now I can come in and kind of
manipulate it a little bit so and also
the way that iPhoto kind of you know
organizes all this stuff makes it much
easier to interact with your old footage
without feeling the need to sit down and
bring it into iMovie and make up and
make an actual video yeah like I have
one from a few weeks ago they created an
album called Saturday evening in Los
Angeles oh that sounds fun
and then there's one rediscover this day
May 16th 2015 and it's two pictures of
my family made into a collage that I
took on that hammock that we used to
have in the backyard hmm so yeah it kind
of brings it up in an innocuous place
where I can enjoy it and be a little
surprised by it but what is the utility
on a Mother's Day movie make a special
movie for a mother in your life oh gosh
too late
what is I do think that what is the
utility of it of having having this
stuff of having your memories captured
in this way you know in a way that
didn't exist into a very recent history
but now it's almost a cliche at this
point to talk about how you document
every every part of your life well what
is the what what's the question what's
the utility of it like what well it's
interesting because I mean it's it's the
one thing across the board that people
are gonna say is that there amongst
their most prized possessions they're
run back into the burning home to get
type of situation but here we are
talking about how much emotional burden
is associated with it
but of course now it's all in the plan I
mean if you don't have all your right
which is what I if you don't have all
your photos and videos in the cloud I
don't know what to tell you if
everything burns so let me ask you this
are you going to look at that honeymoon
footage you said you're gonna sit down
with the kids and do it but it's four
hours of footage what are you gonna do
and and you think that's some popcorn
you said how do you think they're gonna
react to that if you tell them you're
going on a hike and they're hating on it
no they hey kids let's all sit down and
watch daddy and mommy's honeymoon are
you crazy
you think they'll love it they will eat
it up they love old footage of us they
love to hear the way that we talked
Oh without even with even without them
in it and then they love to watch
themselves and yeah yeah I mean we do we
do that all the time we gather around
the computer at home and just go to old
videos and and just it'll be like
alright here's one of Shepard talking
and no one knows what he's saying but
he's very enthusiastic about whatever
his hair looks crazy and he's got food
all over his face so you don't get sad
huh if I completely know what you're
talking about and I've had that like
I'll sit down by myself and look at a
bunch of old stuff and I get this like
sinking I'm old life is life is short
and what am i doing and what is really
important you have this overwhelming
kind of burden on you but when I sit
down with my kids it's like I'm creating
another memory via another memory you
know an older memory so it's just fun
when we do that but if I do it by myself
I get sad so I just don't do it by
myself make it a family thing
maybe I will digitize I mean there were
I remember I didn't take footage of our
honeymoon but on our one-year
anniversary Kristy and I drove down to
Charleston South Carolina and had like a
one-year anniversary second honeymoon
type we can't and I took a lot of
footage of that and then when I got back
home the next over the next few weeks I
edited it into a video and then I was
like I just got one of those like I DVD
burners and I burned it on a DVD yeah
you did I just need to find the DVD yeah
but I remember there was like remember
the DVD menus on a DVD yeah there was
the wedding one the wedding one yeah and
then there was the other ones weren't
the wedding the non wedding ones right
um I don't know which one I use but I
definitely remember that there was
footage there was like bubble bath
footage hold on
you took bubble bath footage yeah of you
and your wife yeah and that's digitized
somewhere it's
yeah I mean it could be you could
probably google and find it no you can't
but oh yeah I wish I would have said
that no I don't have any it's not in the
cloud I don't have any compromising
nobody it's not compromising I don't was
the story get into that I don't have any
compromising photos or videos I I don't
either
anyway so let me let me clarify half the
bubblebath footage okay we the place
that we rented was in downtown
Charleston it was like a historical
bed-and-breakfast like I really went
really went for it but it but they had
fixed this room with a Jacuzzi jacuzzi
tub and then just for you Christie had
bought they know it was that's just in
the room then hear you were coming let's
put it to koozie linked meal is coming
with this with his bride we're gonna
build one here he's brought a video
camera but the bubble bath on build a
jacuzzi and we turned the Jets on that
thing
after Christie just Christie brought all
her own like bubble bath stuff because
we had heard about this fancy tub in our
room and she had doused this thing and
then we turn on the Jets and it was like
an explosion of bubbles that overflowed
not only it like started building up so
high that I ran and grabbed the video
camera and I was just filming the the
the whole room but bubbles really yeah I
came out it was crazy
oh and so I caught the moment in video
form that I've never gone back and
watched except but I did edit it so I
have it in the mix with I mean I was
filming everything you know back then
before you had kids you've filmed
everything for it for a little stretch
and then when you had kids
well you excuse to you keep filming when
you have kids but yeah when I don't
think it I guess it's not kids that made
me stop filming but I remember we were
driving down to Charleston and you know
on you're on i-95 and there's all these
billboards for south of the border oh
yeah every mile for like literally a
hundred miles there's a different
billboard advertising this place just
south of the North Carolina border
called south of the border with Pedro
the mascot yeah which was all these
different billboards culturally
inappropriate a little bit puns with
Pedro you think those are still there
probably they probably are I believe
they are yeah I believe in my heart but
I don't know the truth of it and I
actually I've filmed these you field
every one I filmed a lot of these and
then a big part of the beginning of the
video is a montage he's culturally
inappropriate billboards headed down to
South Carolina you haven't watched that
back I have not watched that back I got
to dig that up and watch it back I mean
the kids would enjoy that
just this morning I this is the this is
the way a person now that we I mean that
could have been for my 18th anniversary
yeah well yeah good luck yeah this is
the way video here like this morning I
went to Shepherds school is into the
year you know and they had a school-wide
assembly and we were told by his teacher
you know Shepherd is winning student of
the month which is why you went yeah and
his teacher also said in the same breath
to my wife when he was explaining this
he's like yeah I mean we we give out we
got 26 students and we give out 20
awards throughout the year and so this
is the 20th it was kind of like he was
saying that like Shepherd just made the
cut sound like that Shepherd was almost
in the six kids who didn't get an award
of any kind but he made the cut those
poor six kids they couldn't him freaking
invent six more Awards I don't know man
you know hey yeah in the in the state
was that he literally got he literally
just made it in the day and age of
participation trophies you least you
throw some of those out there throw the
kid a bone he was the last one huh what
he worried about it was he like dad it's
the last time I haven't gotten an award
remember it was a complete surprise to
him the fact that we dropped him off at
school and he was like this is a little
weird mom and dad are dropping off at
school together that doesn't happen we
were like we're going to breakfast
together
and then which we did so we weren't
lying but then we parked the car I went
inside and he was in the assembly and he
looked back and saw him is very confused
but anyone but but the point of the
story is that Shepard we we're here
everyday we're watching your every move
is that the eye look the kids are all in
this auditorium sitting down and then in
the back in a very small area behind
what the kids are seated all the parents
are standing in about three or four rows
deep of parents all got their phones out
because they're all there apparently
it's not difficult to get student
another month because it seems that like
30 kids got up there but it was one for
every class okay and it was both May and
June they were kind of celebrating
together but anyway I was like I'm gonna
film this but everyone else is all
everyone has their phone out and you
enjoy the moments of your kid
experiencing this thing and you're like
well I'm never gonna remember this
unless I film it and also jesse is
filming it at the same time so like you
see all these husbands and wives
together both filming it both filming it
now she's gonna can make 3d later she's
gonna turn on and post that on she's not
gonna post social media no she's not no
okay cuz if me and Christy were both
filming something or taking a photo
oh yeah I don't my doing this cuz she's
just gonna turn out and put it on her
social media or whatever no it was
posterity also when it but we also you
both don't need to do it that's a little
overkill but I've developed a technique
of holding the phone up getting the
frame where I want it and then taking my
head to the side to be in the moment at
the same time yeah I'm trying to be
present and not look and not enjoy it
through the lens of the camera but make
sure that the lens at the camera is
capturing what I want you need a you
need a forehead camera you need a
something you need a headband how about
Google Google glass that's that's
basically what I need right this is the
best advertiser for Google glass should
and should have never gone away did it
people still wearing that I don't know
but that is ultimately what what I'm
trying to create an experience I can do
that I am filming something now Jesse be
racing
at the same time she'd know and if I she
could do it as she wanted to but if I
began to mansplain to her how to look if
I was like what you really need to do is
you need to be in the moment while
you're filming it and here's the way
that she why don't you take a step you
know what let me put I'll film this and
you don't have to worry about how it's
already committed to it but when I
zoomed in on Shepards face as he was
receiving his award he did not look like
getting student of the month meant much
to him oh he looked like he could have
been finding out anything that did not
matter name something that doesn't
matter to Shepard and that's what looked
what he looked like what's happening to
him and then we were like they were like
okay all parents come up and get
pictures of your kids and all these kids
are smiling super happy to be students
of the month and Shepard just has a
completely blade such a weird kid he's
got a Blaine just blank look on his face
and then I'm like Shepard I'm like
literally at making the and then he
gives this completely fake smile whereas
I stay exactly this head inside the
Month award congratulations son but you
have video of it which you'll never
watch I like to watch it right now you'd
probably laugh at it something but but
now with the AI it'll pop up when you
least expect it and you'll experience
yeah here you have a memory Ennis I love
it now because it's in the cloud you
know a lot of times I didn't take
footage because then I would be a burden
for me to figure out what to do with it
so we're finally we have arrived we're
finally at a point where
your phone's already in your hand you
might as well video or photograph
something and then it's immediately in
the cloud and then the robots assemble
it in a way that you can enjoy at a time
that they think algorithmically you want
to enjoy it this is it
we've arrived no no we haven't arrived
we've just put our foot into the door
because here's what's gonna get really
interesting so you're you're gonna have
something on your body whether it's an
eyepiece that's like a contact or
whether it's your glasses that is doing
exactly what we just
scribed it's allowing you to be present
in the moment as a normal human being
but also be capturing the video and
audio of what you're experiencing and
then for the government though uh-huh
let's not talk about the negative side
before you talk about explore the
positive side and the AI is going to be
so smart that not only is it going to be
able to recall these things but it's
going to be biometrically measuring
things in your body at the time and it's
gonna be measuring your heart rate and
your your breathing and that kind of
thing and it's gonna know when you were
emotionally moved by something it's
gonna know your emotional state that you
were in when you were experiencing these
things and then it'll know how important
it was and then it's gonna know this
meant a lot to link and this is a
special memory or this is when link was
incredibly mad and it's going to be able
to show you there's a lot of muscles in
this one oh boy the bubbles meant
something to you they will be a memory
you will guessing but the the rapid
increase of bubbles tells me that this
is a memory worth featuring and what
will continue to happen which is already
happening as we continue to offload our
minds into these devices and there's no
you know teachers are still teaching
students to memorize all kinds of things
even though ultimately then we're
supplementing our brains with you know
things and it probably still is
important but but I'll I'll add to the
experience because I mean if I go to the
this the reason why I describe sadness
is because you're you're you're looking
at these old things I think part of it
for me is that there are things that
I've forgotten unless I look at the
picture there's lots of memories you
have that aren't memories of the
experience they're memories of the photo
of the experience so I mean we've talked
about how memories are created and
recreated every time you access a memory
it kind of rebuilds in a way that it has
great potential to change or you know so
I to put it simply looking at pictures
from the past it resurfaces and
solidifies memories so if you have a
constant operating record recording of
what's going on in every way including
biometrics and a VR experience by the
way then you can do something like you
can be in a conversation like we're in a
lot of times like you even remember that
you remember that time when me you and
Greg were we were at some park and he
like he tripped in point that was so
funny remember we just laughed our heads
off you'll be honest all that up and
they'll be able to see it based off of
that conversation it can be called up
and not I though that was July 21st 2001
but not only that
not only that because it will be a VR
experience it won't just be a video it
will be the immersed immersive virtual
reality experience because the capturing
technology will basically capture your
field of vision and what you were
hearing at the same time and then you'll
be able to in the middle of that say
switch to Greg's perspective and you'll
be able to relive the memory from Greg's
perspective switch to links perspective
and you'd be able to relive the memory
from everyone's perspective and also I
mean we're just talking about an episode
of black mirror here is not really that
this isn't that revolutionary this is
just what's gonna happen but is this an
episode specific I haven't seen every
episode of black mirror but I kind of
but you haven't seen this one I feel
like they've touched on something very
similar to this somebody I'm sure it has
been but this will be without a doubt
this will be the number one thing used
in court cases right yeah that's why it
won't happen I mean it's it will kind of
privacy yeah yeah no no no I don't think
it will happen well hold on it will
happen because it's legal right now to
wear a virtual reality capture capturing
thing and what people won't opt into it
enough for it to I am you will opt into
it because you want to be able to recall
your memory but what should be continued
to be protected is my ability to tap
into your perspective without a warrant
so you have to let me I'm not saying I'm
saying yeah you have to be you have to
submit to it
saying it should be something that he's
up in some cloud but the problem is as
soon as it's captured and it will be in
cloud anybody who has your password or
anybody who hacks the system is gonna be
able to get to it which ultimately I
just think that that's you know that's
all pretty much inevitable anyway but
it's uh but it'd be pretty cool to see
what it was like to be in Gregg to be in
Gregg shoes when his pants fell down and
he man he fell down well then we fun I
mean do you think that you would opt
into this thing knowing I don't know I I
just I tend to think that I would opt
into this thing for so I could have that
experience to be able to say I want to
go back to the day that my son was born
and experience it and exactly what be
there exactly like it was the the
temptation is too great for the average
person to say no to that I think but
then I remember our first date like
think about that I remember I could the
first time I met my wife the first
conversation I ever had the first words
I ever heard out of her mouth you're
telling me that I can have the ability
in the future well I can't have the
ability but you can have the ability in
the future to access that and perfect in
a perfect vo immersive experience you're
gonna say yes every time there are
people in that with just the event of
camcorders who lived their lives that
way there's not a lot of them but there
are people there's I'm thinking of a
specific documentary where there was a
guy who recorded so much of his life I
can't remember what it is well as you're
thinking about that but you're that's I
think the next genre beyond daily
vlogging now first of all you've got
live streaming and you know like Justine
did that thing with Justin TV she was
one of the first pioneers a 24/7 live
and she wore she wore a camera on her
head but what you're going to be able to
do
the not-too-distant future is someone is
going to be streaming their personal
experience both what they're seeing in
their hearing and you're going to be
able to just live their lives and
there's gonna be people who are in and
there is a movie about this by the way
can't remember which movie it is camera
who's in it but let us know in the
comments because I know you know where
you can inhabit somebody else's
experience and they're gonna be
celebrities and that's gonna be asking
me as Jean rrah it's gonna it's an
inevitable genre of media it's gonna be
this person lives an incredibly cool
life and then you're gonna be able to
just tap into their experience and be
like and again eventually there's gonna
be haptic stuff so you're gonna be able
to not only see and hear what they're
experiencing but you're gonna be able to
feel what they're feeling who they're
feeling yeah you're literally going to
be able to inhabit somebody else's body
and people are gonna be like well my
life is boring but this guy this dude
that it's gonna be this self-fulfilling
prophecy where all of a sudden this
person has all this people are paying
and he's getting you know he's he's
looking at ads he's looking at an ad or
there's an ad rolling in in the middle
of this whole thing to pay for or maybe
you're paying for a service to hack into
this guy's stream but you're gonna begin
to he's gonna become he or she will
become incredibly rich and powerful
because all these people but think about
what that's gonna happen I mean I I
think I don't I don't think that's a
good thing by the way as someone who
looks forward to the transhumanist
experience that kind of stuff scares me
I'm not excited about that it just seems
that's when things start getting very
strange when people are just literally
living vicariously through somebody else
but it will happen it will happen in our
lifetime but you would sign up for the
the 24/7 body documentation life
documentation technology even though you
know that there's so many ways that it
could be exploited that you can't even
anticipate yet that could screw you over
I tend to say I think I would yes I
think I would turn it off
during certain moments moments but you
would probably grow pretty like a days
of cool about that and you would get to
a place where just like I'm gonna leave
it on okay you know it's all encrypted
again it's we talked a little bit about
this weeks ago when we talked about the
ability to read people's thoughts what
we're really getting into is if you can
tap into somebody's experience you're
like one step away from just basically
inhabiting their brain and knowing their
thoughts the the positive spin on all
this is that you get to a place where
you can just tap into somebody else's
perspective and there is no privacy and
we and we're like one step closer to
that whole human organism concept that
we're all incredibly for good reason
uncomfortable with but I'm sure some
ethicist will make very compelling
arguments for why that is not only the
inevitable future that we face but
something we should welcome I think in a
couple of generations it'll be like you
get the fact that you guys were ever
scared of this is ridiculous I think I
think I'm happy with where we are you
know and what about and what if you
could just tap into your kids and first
of all this is an episode of Black
Mirror by the way there's an episode
where there's an implant that a woman a
woman a spoiler alert and not really
gonna spoil it but just in case you
don't want anything spoiled but there's
a there's a girl a little girl who goes
missing for a very short period of time
and the mom has all these horrible
thoughts about what am I gonna do if she
actually gets lost she gets her back but
then she gets the service it's an
implant that basically allows her mom to
pull up an iPad or screen or whatever
the equivalent is in black mirror and
monitor everything that her daughter is
seen but it also allows her to censor
the things that her daughter is seeing
so anything that anything is negative
like even like a dog that's like barking
at her and scaring her is pixelated and
it muffled I
the audio is muffled it plays with some
really interesting themes about privacy
including she keeps this thing she keeps
the distinct as you can't take it out
and there's some really interesting
things that happen as the daughter gets
older and the mom has the ability to tap
into this stream because again you do it
in the name of safety right you're like
like I know where my kid is at at all
times I can know what my kid is seeing
at all times isn't that a positive thing
black mirror always takes basically
expose you how this goes
dark which is great because you cannot
advance in in any of these areas without
being very very familiar with all the
ways that it could go wrong mm-hmm but
you look back on the history of humanity
and there's very few thresholds that we
haven't that we didn't end up crossing
even though we're really scared of it
because once the threshold can be
crossed
it's just eventually there's enough
everybody kind of gives out to the line
and we're all looking at each other like
oh we're gonna cross it and then
somebody pushes in then you're like okay
I guess this is where we're going as a
species it happens in it's inevitable
well I'm happy where I'm at okay listen
the fact that I could just pull up my
phone based on a question in an envelope
and just go all the way back to 2004 was
it except for my license 2006 for me
that's good enough for me yep you know
get a couple of memories served back up
to me but boy a few years later we could
go back to that that time we made
homemade wine wait for your River passed
it back and forth see I fit I feel like
I can go back there in my mind right
that's better it is probably better than
it actually was you're probably right
and we don't buy the way don't have a
choice it was horrible it tasted
horrible it was a fail yeah but we could
change we could reprogram it and make it
taste great that's even worse
you know what that memory that first
that first time we met what we do in our
memories nearly you know you talk to
your partner you're like that first kiss
we had was awkward let's reprogram that
memory
make it great there's an episode of
black Mira editing your memories again
it's probably already been done no
original ideas here
that's the subtitle of our podcast no
original ideas well Carolyn thanks for
your question up I should be more
specific
Carolyn one seven nine eight zero seven
four two sounds like an episode of black
mirror right there her name thanks for
your question
who knows we who knew that we'd go back
more than a decade thanks for hanging
out with us and letting us talk at you
we'll do it again next week
hashtag ear biscuits if you have any
thoughts for us and we'll keep the
conversation going over there hashtag
blessed
[Music]